el pueblo de luqueansi se encuentra a
sólo 8 kilómetros de la frontera rusa
fue ocupado el 24 de febrero el primer
día de la invasión y liberado por el
ejército ucraniano el 11 de septiembre
450 de sus 1.200 habitantes siguen aquí
Sobreviviendo gracias a la ayuda
humanitaria Y a medida que se acerca el
invierno se preocupan
el principal problema ahora es como
pasar el invierno sin gas electricidad
ni agua es imposible hay muchos ancianos
e inválidos postrados en cama si al
menos nos trajeran leña
caterina de 81 años vive sola con su
marido enfermo de parkinson
no llores no llores
no puedo afeitarlo no hay máquinas de
afeitar hoy le he pedido a un soldado
que me consiga algunas tenía muchas pero
las he gastado Todas se las pedí a los
soldados y nunca me las negaron Todo lo
hago yo misma
visión en esta zona es cuyo acceso está
estrictamente controlado por los
militares también falta la medicina
dónde voy a encontrarlos ahora
no se preocupe todo está bien
pero su mayor problema es el invierno
que se avecina
he traído agua del pozo para cocinar y
lavar y quiero poner la cama allí porque
si cocino con una bombona de gas también
se calentará la habitación
infraestructuras de algunas de las zonas
liberadas han quedado completamente
destruidas por los intensos combates las
autoridades ucranianas dicen que están
reparando lo que pueden una tarea enorme
desalentadora aún más difícil por las
minas terrestres y los continuos
bombardeos